German Chancellor Angela Merkel is
wrapping up her two-day visit to Japan
on Tuesday she met with University
students stressing again the need for a
new multilateral approach to global
trade talking at scale University Merkel
addressed the ongoing trade dispute
between the US and China saying that
Germany and Japan would be the first to
feel a fallout if Chinese consumption
collapses due to the trade tensions now
asked about business relations with
China and ongoing concerns about data
protection Mackel also spoke about the
role Chinese technology giants yourway
could play in the German
telecommunications landscape here's what
she said it's a corset discussion here
in Germany there's currently a big
discussion about Huawei and whether to
use it that's something that needs to be
discussed with China that the company
doesn't simply hand over data to the
government German consumers need to be
certain that the Chinese state isn't
getting access to data on Chinese
products that are sold in Germany
producted through - con so German
Chancellor and go maca they are talking
to students in Tokyo and for more on
Angela Merkel's two-day visit to Japan
I'm joined now by key word era from DW
business good to have you here in the
studio Kia so when it comes to China to
Japan and Germany see eye to eye well
they have a lot of a lot in common both
Japan and Germany are exporting nations
as we know and that's why they also
quite dependent on the trade with China
and China's for example the most
important trading partner in Asia for
Germany but also the dependence that
makes both of them quite wary for
example we had the thing with Merkel
she's voicing concerns about your way as
well and in Japan that's quite similar
because they also have big stakes in Ko
away whatever happens to them also
happens to Japan thing also is we also
heard about Germany's high-tech sector
being a bit scared of China buying a lot
of their companies like cuca the robot
maker and Japan in general is just not
that happy about the fact that China is
stealing the spotlight for them so it is
all
question and the threat of losing you
know intellectual property of course and
Germany and Japan certainly have another
thing in common it's they're both aging
societies and both if you like industry
champions struggling a little bit Japan
more so Germany starting now this closer
relationship also in in research you
know is this going to be beneficial for
both well in a way we can't really
forget they are aging societies they
have a lot of problems but they're still
the third and fourth biggest economies
in the world but I think especially in
the AI sector and also in the autonomous
driving sector they promised that
they're going to work together they've
promised also to work together on IIT
beforehand and it's you never know how
much is going to get out of it because
there is a lot of competition about the
aging Society Japan is the most the
oldest Society I think in the world and
it's not handling the problem well at
all there is no solution really that
Japan can present a Germany and be like
oh hey look you know do what we've been
doing so in that region that I don't
think there's gonna be that much synergy
well maybe that's why robots play such a
big role in Japan today already that
we've heard over the last couple of days
an awful lot about those close relations
between Germany and Japan how close are
they well on an everyday level I think
there is a lot of love between the two
countries Japanese people are really in
love with German people on the other
hand also there is a good relationship
but the two Merkel and Abin know each
other have been known each other for I
think over 10 years now it's a very
special relationship I think very
harmonious especially compared to the
relationship to China or also to the
u.s. there were a bit the Japanese were
a bit upset actually that Merkel has
been to China for 11 times and this is
only the fifth state visit to Japan so
in terms of quantity the relationship
isn't quite as deep it appears exact
adora there thank you so much
you